what's up everybody definite Jason
McCourty we're about to play start [ __ ]
cut and we're here Mountain Dew zero
sugar man having a good time down here
in Miami we're gonna be giving a
category we got a big one to start bench
and cut remember the titans start Friday
Night Lights [ __ ] cut Rudy ah you got
to cut Rudy
I'll put Rudy on a bench just you no no
Rudy Vallee Night Lights and I hate to
do it but I'm gonna cut the Titans
because the Titans got me starting
blueprint just cuz jay-z I'm from New
York I'm going to bench 50 cent don't
keep them on the team get rich or die
trying' and I'm not from the south so no
man gotta go but I still I agree with
that
that's exactly what I want to do
starting whiskey benching tequila
buckles when I was younger son cut yeah
yeah we're gonna cut vodka start to kill
it oh and [ __ ] whiskey I couldn't
answer for him I know where he's gonna
start Serena Williams bench
Tom Brady huh
nah but Vince Tiger Woods cut Tom Brady
hey that's how I go sometimes that's how
I go I still love you though Tom cut
seven where did start pizza a [ __ ] the
wings on pizza no start to win so many
flavors flavors I'm told I'm with a big
Ross I'm a pepper
yeah I mean I banged with little
probably barbecued oh you got to have a
barbecue win no ha this is Devon taste
McCourty man and that would start bench
and cut